okay so to start off I'm at my brother's
place right now because the power once
again went off I mean it just every time
there's a thunderstorm in Chicago on the
weather they should just have a power
outage sign cuz that's just like it's
like the third time this year so I'm
just gonna say right now I don't know
when this will go out but if the
editorial this week is nothing that
great or if one even pops up or anything
just that's the reason easily the last
airbender Ruby no no last airbender is
going out that there had to be another
power outage for that but the editorial
will probably be delayed because I want
to use the I would put to that to the
last airbender because that's I've been
building that up like fuck man and I'm
not all my orgies gonna go into that but
we got the charity drive doing all this
stuff so whatever that's why I'm here
that's and that's why if the editorial
has already gone out that's why it was
probably so late or rushed or whatever
but with asset okay we got Korra here
and obviously Robinson this one this is
the final three this is it my place yeah
SSR goes without saying but this is the
final three is to turn of the tides and
holy shit it's like where were you
episode it's like I was waiting for this
effort so it's finally here it's like
yes this one is so good
what were you sit oh this is like The
Dark Knight ride what the Dark Knight
Rises shit about it yeah yeah I know
it's like saying this feels like a
Christopher Nolan movie this episode in
particular like I reminds you that scene
where the Joker was taking out everybody
in the middle of the movie and like you
know they get all the councilmen in this
episode
yeah well the Councilwoman to open up an
envelope this has all been there like
she ya know we're talking about um no
yeah this is I love this episode but I
yeah well I'm not gonna go into the
whole show yet but oh yeah I because he
said he knows so what happens but ya
know what when he comes down it just as
citizens of Republic shithole you know
but again when it's suck if feels like I
will get revenge for the cabbage
salesman know that be stupid you see
Amon is doing his own thing that's why
Dark Knight rice it's that but okay the
listen Dark Knight Rises this is what it
should've been and yeah man just all
this shit goes down and
here's what I've realized now because I
think I serve bitched and moaned a
little bit about what the problem was
with some of the characters and I
realized specifically uh just on him
this anything connected to Tenzin's
circle his family uh Lin even Cora is
good the the councilman and Tarr logins
and all that stuff is really good I
realized anything connected to Cora's
circle seems to be where a lot of the
faults are sort of mock oh and what was
it bullying is is that the poem in a
bowl in and and the daughter and the
love triangle asking me by the way when
I'm the one who's gonna get you in more
trouble yeah yours that's that's what
this is you just want to get me in
trouble oh I just just for anyone
wondering by the way is Sokka and
Katara's can't believe a really really
bad guy sighs look we're doing our own
blood bending it's like you know what
it's like we're gonna say the names
wrong a purpose and there's no give is
wrong like I hope I literally like
pronounced it wrong once or twice just
to get you to get them nice it's like it
is it's like being a blood bender it's
like wow that's power I could get drunk
it was fun this is for us it's like we
said it before like editor oh okay okay
lowing somebody's somebody yesterday's
just like well well don't just make sure
that Rob just isn't in any of the games
like a sheriff yeah it's like the next
day I'm in one now I'm just like enjoy
so know it so that was a way that that
was joy something special that that's
something only the stupidity of certain
online viewers can give you so oh so
just thank you for that that it kind of
made our way I just want to known still
for the record to this very day that I
am NOT the problem with Sookie though I
told you to pronounce that one right I
know that now let's say I know how live
you are was like okay but okay we're
getting really on top it right I'm on
the same show right now we're at about
Cora um so yeah because for me what I
what I found is that with that team and
again they're not god-awful or anything
they're just sort of very formulaic and
we've seen in and
even kind of bland ah but it's special
with a love triangle because I always
see like every single time I'm really
getting into it's like so do you have
feelings for Korra it's just like oh
shut up the city's blowing up can we go
back to that and it just it drives me
nuts and it could be worse but it still
drives me they gotta be way worse I
thought for the most part it was pretty
unintrusive I'm like you know when it's
all said and done like maybe it's
because I've sat through a lot more bad
anime than you have but I'm like for a
love triangle because I thought the same
thing initially I was like iceberg right
ahead turn around this is gonna suck and
I'm like when it's all said and done
like what are we on ten now episode 10
yeah um it's not that intrusive my day
to make it focused so much on it I'd
probably be born away but it easy if
they stopped at that one episode where
it began it's like okay we picked our
mates and everything let's go here it's
like it I would have been okay as I
thought I was a little knowing but
whatever but they're still keeping it
going and they're not needed but the
other thing is again sitting through
love triangles that have been really
really really god-awful the characters
are not at least a complete waste no I
thought there kind of there's Sally boy
and yes maka was the daughter could be
interesting they gave her more but she's
sort of rajesh but here's the thing
they're not bad though well they don't
that annoy me yeah they're not obnoxious
at the same time perfectly reasonable
here but aren't you constantly saying
yeah what's going on with Tencent what's
going on with Lynne what's going on with
hel the kids
tensions kids who really kick ass in
this episode by the way I could use more
of a tenses yes um okay the farthest we
can get the far fending is really God
stupid but you know I'll take that over
the fucking love triangle any day
I've watched like a whole half-hour of
fart bending over any of us I don't
relish comments Caravaca I'm glad I mean
it's stupid but I don't get slack for
that one what the fart fellow I have had
so many people be like no cable ooh they
did their firebending in this like so
stupid my my try have that over the love
triangle
any day um again I'm not a huge fan of
it I'd but I guess what it is I just
don't think it's that bad
it you bring up okay you do bring up a
good point the creators of this show the
writers of the show I think this may be
the issue they're really good at the
sort of high fantasy Asian influence uh
Taoist kind of philosophical Zen thing
they may just not it may be a write what
you know that you know they may just not
be good at writing you know teen
romances as well as their that um well
you know it sound like I was watching
behind the CC now I'm trying to read up
on those behind the scenes stuff on
avatar the creators and stuff like that
and it seemed like they were saying look
we love like you said the whole dousing
the Zen thing an agent philosophy uh but
we also do sort of like just typical
American young bullshit you know they
say we like this stuff to it we like to
incorporate it and a lot of times it's
worked in very well you know here it
just seems like especially for something
supposed to be more adult it just seems
like this big step backwards I will say
this though the most I didn't carries it
kara bokura yeah not gonna be here II
that was a slip of a tongue I believe
Cora is a pretty adult
I think she's mostly a pretty adult
character I mean she has mistakes you
know she well in that they're showing
what she's going through they're showing
that age I'm ready well she's a teenager
so they got that I think though these
guys are really really good at writing
adult characters and the kids in the in
the avatar last airbender and sort of an
adult side to them like they treated the
characters yes seriously they went
through their own story arcs you know
they had to learn things and I think we
see that here it's like Tenzin Lin
beifong like those are the two most
adult characters in this show for me
like Lin beifong and Tenzin in
particular we were talking about this
how they have the most adult
relationship you know yeah they used to
do it all feels triangle yeah they had a
long time work so much you get this idea
of the history like and what an
interesting character to cuz I was
thinking that I've been talking online
about strong female characters here's
one I don't see a lot the strong
middle-aged well-known essay you might
not see it maybe even older and I mean
totally kicks ass and again oh yeah like
their late middle age they look like
she's getting gray hair he's bald and
you know he well to be fair I think yeah
yeah but yes he's definitely old so yeah
I just that's great I just never see
that that much and I was like and I told
us we try it I told ya yes I'm like I
believe it in a family show to where you
know like the and it's not like always
in that face of an older lady swinging
around and kicking ass no it's like
legit and you totally buy it and I
really like that too I thought that was
really cool you know they did so great
for younger younger characters and now
they're doing even better with older
characters as well yeah I think they're
really good at writing adult characters
and I think they're good at writing kid
characters in an adult sort of way kids
don't say you know I don't want to say
this is their kryptonite because I still
think it's a good show but this may just
be the weaker thing and all of the
things they're doing that maybe this was
the one thing that yeah they're not
quite as strong added as they were these
other characters yeah and I
or maybe just not as interested in it
maybe they're just like yeah you know we
wanted to do romance but it may not be
our thing like you know I don't know
yeah you know and so the same thing with
the pro-bending it's like anything just
sort of tied in with that world it's
like it's not got off I always want
emphasize and like it doesn't make this
a bad show I disagree I think they
really liked pro-bending thought it was
cool and that's what oh oh no no I'm
sure they did I'm just saying again
anything connected with that worlds I
get first it's kind of cool but then
like three or four episodes it's like
God come on can't get down the stuff we
had in this episode I couldn't get
enough of the pro-bending oh gotta get
Shane to the set do something different
so sick of look at those same colors and
it's like cuz that first it's also been
like four episodes in come on give me
something else I was so happy when the
mom came instead fuck this bullshit I'm
taking away your bending so these games
are over I'm like yeah I be I was just
so looking forward to that I'll bet you
hated Quidditch too I can't
but today the Quidditch and so did you
don't have plays yeah yeah oh that's
different that was seven movie 12
episode yeah this is yeah this is four
episodes out of the 12 that's
practically seven movies um so okay for
Ian sidetracked uh but bottom bending
was cool learning yes I agree but that's
not that big regardless uh episodes
awesome talk about the ending real fast
uh what's your top day Bosco's boys go
bad that just like fuck haha that's just
and you see that plea that's like I was
always reaction I was a prisoner for
epic this is what I was waiting for it's
like in a finally gather I'm just like
thank you show thank you you know safe
before it's like this show is made it's
done at the same thing with avatar
though it's like it's almost like
somehow they can hear the V logs cuz I'm
like I really like if they do this and
then they go and do it somehow it's I I
don't know they have a time machine or
my opinion is important up to get a time
machine to come back and do change it I
it could be favorite episode so far man
by far there's two left I hope they're
just as good because I man did I like
this episode this was really really good
stuff so um yeah does he have the next
one